I believe death is the ultimate freedom
so I'd rather just have my freedom as
soon as as soon as I can get it so
you're saying you actually prefer giving
the death penalty to being in prison for
life
yes say you do get a long sentence how
are you going to spend your life I
haven't decided yet it seemed and you
got a lot of questions from the jury
they seem like some of those jurors
didn't believe what you were telling
them bigger story I can understand that
I think because of what I was the lies
that I told in the beginning to try to
cover up this cover-up that hide things
that I didn't want to be known you made
public so if you had to do this all over
again you're in the desert you notice
that you got blood on your hands how do
you handle it I would turn around and
drag to the Mesa police department hey
what do you think would have happened to
you that I don't know but it would have
been the right thing